Over the past several decades, the term implicit bias has moved from the relative obscurity of academia into everyday usage. The concept is also at the center of recent debates over how society should think about and teach about racism, prejudice, and discrimination. The idea that we all have biases that operate below the level of our conscious thought may be uncomfortable. But decades of research have found that many people who would never consciously agree, with prejudice statements about black people, LGBTQ people, or women, for example, can nonetheless harbor implicit biases toward these groups and others.
在过去几十年里，内隐偏见这个词从鲜为人知的学术界走入了日常使用。
So what is implicit bias and where does it come from? What's the connection between implicit bias and prejudice? How are they different and how are they connected? How do implicit biases influence our behavior? Is it possible to unlearn or overcome our biases? Does educating people about implicit bias help to reduce it, and as a society, are we shedding any of our biases? Do they remain as strong as ever? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association
那么，什么是内隐偏见？
that examines the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Mazarin Banaji. Dr. Benaji is a professor of psychology at Harvard University and a pioneer in researching implicit bias. Together with her colleague Anthony Greenwald, she coined the term and ran the first studies on it in the 1990s. Today, Dr. Banaji continues to study the disparity between what people think they believe and their thoughts and feelings that operate on an unconscious level. She is co-author of the 2013 book, Blind Spot, Hidden Biases of Good People, and has won many awards and honors for her work, including most recently the 2022 Atkinson Prize in Psychological and Cognitive Sciences from the National Academy of Sciences.
这正是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）所主持的播客节目。
She also won APA's 2017 Award for Distinguished Scientific Contributions. Thank you for joining me today, Dr. Benaji. Thank you for having me. In the public discussion over implicit bias, the term often gets conflated with prejudice or racism. Can you start our discussion by explaining what implicit bias is and how it's different from bias and prejudice? Implicit bias is definitely not racism. It gets used that way, but that's incorrect. For much of the 20th century, social psychologists who were interested in the topic of prejudice
她还曾获得美国心理学会2017年杰出科学贡献奖。
and how could they not be, the field almost got its start during the war years, during World War II, when larger numbers of scholars and scientists from Germany were coming to the United States. for some reason on the top of their mind was the topic of prejudice. So they studied it in the way in which they could. They asked people questions about who they loved and hated. They asked people more subtle questions about the kinds of policies they might support to try to get at this concept called prejudice. Prejudice to psychologists is an explicit, conscious, aversion or dislike that one person may have
他们会询问人们关于他们爱谁、恨谁的问题。
towards groups of people. If I were to say to you, I do not think that women should be teaching at Harvard. That would be an example of something we would call a conscious prejudice. What we've studied and what the modern, the invention of computers that allowed us to do experiments that would get at other levels of our minds, what that work revealed was that a large number of people in our society have genuinely, honestly, come to a point where they believe that they are not biased. And that, I would argue, is true. This is not something that they're making up. This is not something that they're lying about.
如果你对我说，我不认为女性应该在哈佛大学教书。
They genuinely believe in the ideals of egalitarianism, equal treatment, fair treatment, and they disavow prejudice. They teach their children how to not be prejudiced and so on. And yet, what our evidence showed is that those very same people, I would say people like your listeners, people like myself, we found that we do have what we call implicit levels of bias. It is not at all the same thing as racism or sexism, but it indeed is evidence of an association in our heads that I would call the roots of prejudice. Where do these implicit biases come from? How do we learn them since we're not really aware of
他们教导自己的孩子如何不抱偏见，等等。
them. You're right to use the word learn because we're not born knowing that African Americans are bad and white people or European Americans are good. We do not, we're not born into the world believing that men should be going out to work and women should be at home. So learning is what happens. But it would be remiss, I think, not to speak a little bit about what we mean here by learning. What we mean here by learning is something that happens extremely fast, quite early in life and then progresses. And that comes not from just the social environment, but by the structure and the architecture of our minds, the way our brain got built over a period of evolutionary history. So we have a certain kind of a brain as humans. And we tend to focus on the conscious aspects of what
你用“学习”这个词是正确的，因为我们生来并不知道非裔美国人不好，而白人或欧裔美国人就好。
our minds allow us to do. I consciously logged in today, you are consciously speaking to me today about the topic of implicit bias. This is what makes humans so unique and different than any other species. But there are many other parts of our brains where work is happening quite outside of conscious awareness. And that's a very smart way for a system to be. You know, a simple computer, not anything like as complex or as magnificent as our brains is doing a lot of work. that's not visible to us on our monitors. It's churning out data. It's putting things together.
我今天是有意识地登录的，你今天是在有意识地跟我谈论内隐偏见这个话题。
It's updating stuff. It's doing all of that work quite outside of our ability to visualize it. Why? That's what makes that computer smart. It's doing a whole bunch more stuff. And it doesn't need to start everything up every single time. These are routines. It has learned we call them compiled programs that are set to deal with certain things that
为什么？
happen all the time. We have those two. And some of those compiled programs, that we have and that we carry in our minds have the vestiges of the past. They are left inside of our heads and in the ways in which our brain works that come from a time and a place in our history where we lived with people who were just like us. They were genetically identical to us in our own little tribe of 30 people, 150 people, or whatever.
我们也有这些程序。
On the other side of the mountain from which our ancestors lived was another group of people who maybe were different from us because they put a different mark on their face or wore a different kind of clothing, but they were genetically also jigs the same as us. And yet when the two met, especially at some resource like food or water, and when it looked like only one of us could have that resource, we learned that we had to do certain things, not very nice things to other people in order to survive. Some of that has been left in our brains. even though our world has changed dramatically. So I always argue that, that, you know, if we just go back to something that's attributed
其中一些甚至留在了我们的脑海中，留在了我们大脑的工作方式中。
to Darwin, that it is not the strongest who will survive, nor the most intelligent, but the ones who are most adaptive to change. If we believe that, then what we're speaking about today is that kind of adaptation, because in the old world, perhaps it was reasonable, rational, to be suspicious of people who looked very different from us. But today, the way our world is set up, it's the exact opposite that is being called for if we want to succeed, if we want to adapt.
如果你相信这一点，那么我们今天讨论的就是那种适应性，
And that is, if a business person looks at somebody very different from them, I think it would be worthwhile for that business person to say, how can I outsource to that person and make a lot of money for my business? So you see how our moment is calling for a very different kind of approach and a different kind of behavior
那就是，如果一个商业人士看到一个与他截然不同的人，我认为对这个商业人士来说，值得思考的是：我如何把工作外包给这个人，从而为我的企业赚大钱？
than the one that paid off in the long past. And that is part of the reason why we fail, because not only is the stuff invisible, it also, the natural orientation would be towards similarity or familiarity and so on, which today is not necessarily going to be suited. I have to go find people who know things I simply don't know, which means people from different fields,
这也是我们失败的部分原因，因为这些东西不仅是隐形的，而且人们的自然倾向也是朝向相似性或熟悉度等等，而在今天，这未必适用。
people from different cultures. So I have to do something that almost goes against my nature. Let me ask you how you got interested in this topic. I understand that you began your career studying memory. So how did you move from memory to implicit attitudes? And where's the connection? So I'm one of those very fortunate people who came to be in a field at a time when clearly something was happening.
所以我必须做一些几乎违背我本性的事情。
Other people had cleared the brush. And I happened to stand on the shoulders of giants. Yes, I was interested in human memory. I had zero interest in social groups or bias. I wasn't looking for research to do on that topic. But in the process of doing research on memory, and this is the fortunate part, a little revolution was happening in the field of human memory. People who had been studying memory for over 100 years since Ebbinghaus in the late 1800s
其他人都已经披荆斩棘。
were studying memory using one kind of measure. we would ask people, what did you eat for breakfast today? Or what happened to you when you were five years old? Or you just learned a list of words in the lab. Tell me what those words are. However different the content may be, what was similar to all these methods, all these questions, was a single method. And that is that the method required us, the human whose memory was being tested, to go into her mind and pull out some of the method. something consciously, because you'd have to do that to answer those questions. Today, we call that form of memory explicit memory, because it requires an explicit action that requires conscious awareness to go into our minds, to pull out something from the past. What was happening at the time I came to graduate school in the 1980s is a recognition that there might be another form of memory that we had. That simply did not respond to questions like that.
然而，无论内容多么不同，所有这些方法、所有这些问题都有一个共同点，那就是单一的方法。
These data came from amnesic patients, these data came even from ordinary people who were not amnesics, showing that there is stuff that gets laid down in our brain through our experiences that we may have no recollection of. And yet, if you use the right test, the right probe, you might find evidence for it. And so one such study that I remember picking not quite at random, but almost, to present in a brown, bag on memory that we used to run. My colleague Rob Crowder, who studied auditory memory, and I at Yale University, where my first job was, we ran a little group called the Memory Lunch Group, where we would talk about studies on memory. And I decided to present a study done by a genius cognitive psychologist by the name of Larry Jacoby and his colleagues. And what Larry had done is shown people
这些数据来自失忆症患者，这些数据甚至来自并非失忆症患者的普通人，这表明有些东西通过我们的经验被储存在我们的大脑中，而我们可能对此毫无记忆。
names that he had pulled out of a phone book, say a name like Sebastian Weisdorf. And then people who read those names from the phone book went away, and then they came back a day or two later. And now he gave them a new list of names. That list consisted of the names they had seen before, Sebastian Weistorf, but also new names like Timothy Watson that were not famous names, but from the same phone book. And then he added into that list names of some famous people. Wayne Gretzky was such a name at the time he was known, a famous Canadian hockey player, names of athletes, names of film stars, rock musicians, whatever it was. Now imagine you're the subject in this study.
现在想象一下，你是这项研究中的被试。
You came on day one and you saw some names and you went away and now you've come back. And before you is a list of names. These studies were done with paper and pencil. And this is a long list of names. It has some old names, some new names. some new names, all not famous, and then mixed in was some famous names. And the task was very simple. This is what I loved about the experiment. Larry said to the subjects and his, you know, just look at each name and just say yes or no, is this the name of a famous person or not. So if people were to
这些研究是用纸笔进行的。
respond accurately, they should say Wayne Gretzky, yes, famous, but Timothy Watson and Sebastian Weisdorf, not famous. But that didn't happen. What he showed, is that indeed Timothy Watson was identified as not famous correctly. But now think about Sebastian Weisdorf. A name you saw the day before appears again, and it has a quality that he called perceptual fluency. When you read the name Sebastian Weisdorf, it looks familiar to you. But your brain doesn't remember whether Sebastian Weisdorf is now a football player
但事实并非如此。
or a rock star or a name you saw the day before. This becomes confusing, and in that moment, implicit memory kicks in and people wrongly identify Sebastian Weisdorf as famous. He called this result becoming famous overnight by just showing that, you know, when things are not consciously, if you were consciously able to recognize
这让人感到困惑，在那一刻，内隐记忆发挥了作用，人们错误地将塞巴斯蒂安·魏斯多夫识别为名人。
that Sebastian Weisdorf was a name you saw two days ago, I think you would legitimately reject it as a famous name. But because we've forgotten and especially forgotten time information, place information, where did this happen, when did this happen, then the rest of the stuff starts to look familiar and you use that as the basis of this incorrect judgment. I was, I just thought this was a very cool study and I decided to write to Jacoby and get the materials for the study to replicate them. And this is in 1989. because his study appeared in that basic. And I asked him for the material, as we did in those old days,
我当时就觉得这是一项非常酷的研究，并决定写信给雅各比，获取该研究的材料来进行重复实验。
we used to actually have little postcards that we had printed up and that we would fill in the name of the article and write the address of the person and put it in U.S. mail. And then you would wait. You would check your physical mailbox every day because you are expecting a big fat Manila envelope. And one arrived with all of the materials that Professor Jacoby generously sent to me. As I looked at the materials, I noticed that all the names, you know, famous and not famous were male men's names.
当我看着这些材料时，我注意到所有的名字，无论是著名的还是不出名的，都是男人的名字。
And as I tell the story, you know, I wrote him another postcard. Like, Dr. Jacoby, you only sent me half your stimuli aware of the other half. I didn't actually do that. I did talk to him about it, though. And he said, but women are not famous. And if we, you know, it just, and you know, when he said that to me, it made complete sense. Sure. Like if you want to do a psychological, you know, study, you would have to, on memory, which is not on gender, the question was, why would you bother to get equal, because now you'd have to get equal numbers of famous males and females? It's just not relevant to the study. So often in research, we take that path of finding the most, the best stimuli. And the best stimuli in this case would have been to keep everything constant to use just men's names. Now, I understood that. But this is what I'd love your listeners to think about. Something made me spend an entire summer
正如我讲述这个故事时所说，我给他写了另一张明信片。
coming up with equally famous, I tried, equally famous men and women's names. I was not successful in coming up with equally famous men's and women's names, but I did that. You know, I went to books and I looked at, you know, nothing on the internet, of course, so it was hard to do, but I would test small groups of people and try to come up with names, you know, like Jane Austin or whatever, so that many people would recognize. And so I just did what I thought was a replication of the Jacobi study, but just with both kinds of names in it, expecting, of course, full well that the same result should happen for male names and female names. Why should that be different? Once you had become familiar with a name like Sally Weisdorf, you should now be more
但在六次实验中，我发现的结果是这样的。
likely to say Sally Weisdorf was famous, just like you did for Sebastian Weisdor. But in six experiments, what I found. I was surprised. Initially I just thought it was a throwaway result and I would just let it go and say you know the women's names did not become famous overnight the way the men's names did. But as I thought about it I began to quiz my subjects. I used to run my own experiments in those days I ran every single subject and I would say to them at the end of the study. So what do you think you used as the rule to identify fame? Not one of them said the gender of the name. So then I started to say to them, do you think you might have
起初我只认为这是一个被抛弃的结果，我打算随它去，并说你知道的，女性的名字并没有像男人的名字那样一夜成名。
used the gender of the name in making your decision? And they would look surprised and sometimes even offended. What do you think I am a sexist? Of course, I wasn't using the gender of the name. And yet, that was so clearly in the data. I did a presentation at a conference in which I think I took the bold step of saying, I've quizzed, you know, 400 subjects, a book. about this. Not one of them was aware that he or she was using the gender of the name to decide on the person's likelihood of fame. And yet, in their data, we saw this. If this is true, then harm is happening without the person doing the harm being aware that they're doing it. The person being harmed is not going to be aware that she was harmed. What does this mean
这对于关于我们将如何在民主社会中互相对待的宏大问题意味着什么？
for the big question of how we're going to treat each other? in a democratic society where we believe that fairness and egalitarianism and so on are the virtues we care about. And that's where it started. That's pretty amazing. Well, one of the best known ways today to test implicit bias is through something you were involved in creating the implicit association test. How did that come about? How does that test work? So the credit here goes to my colleague Tony Greenwald, who, again, I think even he didn't come to it with an interest in creating something that became the IAT. He was really dissatisfied with the methods that we were using at the time to get at implicit bias that weren't really that powerful. We would get differences
那么这里的功劳要归功于我的同事托尼·格林沃尔德（Tony Greenwald）。
and you can't do, you know, one fame study after another is the way to study implicit bias. Something more general was needed. We did have a method. in psychology. It's called semantic priming. If I flash a word rapidly on a computer screen and the word is something like soldier, let's say. If the word that follows it is John, you'll be much more quickly able to identify John than if the word is Jane. Because Soldier and John go together in our memory and in our minds and our understanding rather than Soldier and Jane. And likewise, you know, if I said something like Nurse and John, you'd be slower to. respond to John after nurse than you would be to Jane. So that was a method. I was using that method.
如果我在电脑屏幕上快速闪现一个词，这个词比如说是“士兵”。
It was producing good data, but it was inefficient. You know, you would need to give people 800 trials. Imagine a poor subject sitting at a computer, you know, 800 times having to answer these questions and for a whole hour. And then the effect size was small. It was always there. So for the scientists doing research on understanding the human mind, it was perfectly okay. But you, the subject, if you were taking that test, you wouldn't necessarily have the feeling or the experience that you were showing a bias. And what Tony Greenwald did is tried the slightly different way of trying to get at the strength of association between A and D in our minds. The way the IAT or the implicit association test works is actually quite simple. It makes the assumption
IAT（内隐联想测验）或内隐联想测验的工作原理其实很简单。
that if two things have co-occurred in our experience over and over again, that we'll put those two things together very quickly. Salt and pepper is just a simple example, okay? Bacon and eggs, if you want to stay with food-related things. But mother and father or father and he, mother and she, these are things that have co-occurred in our experience, and therefore they have a strong connection. Neuroscientists have a little phrase that they use to teach people about learning of that kind,
盐和胡椒就是一个简单的例子，好吗？
and their phrase is a very useful one. When they speak about neurons, they say, what fires together, wires together. And that's what we are trying to get at. We know that some things have fired together. Can we build a method that will give us an indication of how strongly they're wired together? And so the IAT works in a very simple way. it requires you, and I would say to your listeners, there is no way in which you will appreciate the IAT by listening to what I say as much as you will by taking a test.
神经科学家有一个小短语，他们用来向人们教导这种学习，
Right, which anyone can do, and we'll include a link in the show notes, yeah. So what happens in an IAT, and let's just take something like gender and work, in our experience, even though women have entered the workforce in very large numbers, in our minds, male and career, to the extent that they're more closely associated, should get picked up on a test like the following. You see names of men and women, a name like Peter may show up, a name like Susan may show up. You're told, use two keys on your keyboard. If you see a male name, press the left key. If you see a female name, press the right key. So easy to do. Now we say, okay, we're going to now give you words that mean home and career words. If you see a work like child or marriage or garden or
那么在IAT中会发生什么呢？
kitchen, you will press the right key. If you see a career word, a word like office, manager, job, briefcase, desk, things like that, you will press the left key. And now what you're doing the IAT, and this is the critical moment, you combine them. So you say, all right, you're going to see all four kinds of things, male, female, home, career. For now, if it's a male name like Peter or a office-related word like boardroom or a briefcase, press the left key. So you're putting those two together. If it's a female name like Susan or a word like kitchen from home, you press the right key. It's very easy for us to do that because that set of trials is picking up what we think of
如果你看到一个女性名字，比如苏珊，或者一个来自家庭的词，比如厨房，你按右键。
as the established stereotypical association. So if you're taking a test when you have to do that, you're whizzing through it. You're making very few mistakes and your speed to response, which is our critical measure, time to respond, call a response latency in milliseconds. But what happens, unbeknownst to you, you're now told, okay, you did very well. Now let's get you to do something a little different. Now put Peter and Kitchen together and put Susan and boardroom together using these keys on the keyboard. Very simple.
很简单。
And everybody thinks, oh, I should be able to do that. Nobody thinks that they can't do that. I should be able to imagine Peter in the kitchen, Susan in a boardroom. No problem. Until you start to do it. And so people like me who have always had a career, I was born and raised in South India. My mother, in a society where women didn't work outside the home, did, and was a teacher. In spite of all of these direct personal experiences, I can't.
直到你开始动手去做。
I can't do this. I can't do it as fast as I could do the previous version. And when, you know, so when after those Jacoby experiments that I had done earlier, you know, we had to come up with a name for this thing. And we were struggling with the name. And because I'd been studying memory and the phrase that they were using was implicit memory, to distinguish it from conscious or explicit memory, we called this implicit. bias because it was now showing an ability to do one thing faster than the other as a measure of what I call the thumbprint of the culture on our brain. That's not always consistent with your view of yourself. And that's the dissociation. So in psychology, the term dissociation is an important one when in this case, it's where your data on one measure, When I explicitly ask you, you'll say one thing.
这不是总是与你对自己的看法保持一致。
But on then the implicit measure, something different is showing up. So I show no bias if you ask me a survey question about who belongs more at home and who belongs more in the workplace. I will tell you equally men and women. And then you give me this test and it's not anything close to equal. I'm just unable to do it. And we believe the test picks up the thumbprint of the culture on our brain. So is it possible to learn to overcome these implicit biases? So you train yourself out of responding in that way. And when you take the test, it doesn't show up that way anymore.
所以，如果你问我关于谁更属于家庭、谁更属于工作场所的调查问题，我不会表现出偏见。
You're actually able to relate things that wouldn't normally be related because you've done something to rewire your brain. Is that possible? The best way to answer that question is to say, of course. Of course it can be changed because it was learned. So you could make yourself. unlearn it. But the mistake that people make is to think that they can unlearn it easily. Right? You think to yourself, okay, first, I don't want to believe that I have bias. That's the first sort of defense. So you argue and you argue and you argue until you have been hemmed into a box from which you can't escape that shows you that bias does exist in your head. So then you agree.
回答这个问题的最好方法是说，当然可以。
And then you say, oh, but I'll just tell myself not to be that way. And that's the stake. So we should be aware. So there are many experiments that have been done in my lab recently, but in many other people's labs, where we try to look at what is it that will change an existing implicit bias. The work of Calvin Lai at Washington University is very important here because he set these experiments up as a competition. You, if you were a scientist interested in this question, you could submit what you think is your best intervention to change data on the IAT. I won't go into the details. It's a long, laborious way to take all these people's ideas and turn it into a proper
加州大学圣路易斯分校的卡尔文·赖（Calvin Lai）的研究在这里非常重要，因为他将这些实验设置为一场竞赛。
experiment where every intervention gets a fair shot at changing people's minds. He did it with race, so we can begin with the race IAT, where 70% of white people and even Asians associate white with good and black with bad. you can begin with something like that. And then he asked people, come up with a certain minutes. I forget how long, but your intervention can't be longer than a few minutes. What do you think would work? And it's a lovely way to do science because you're not prejudging what will work and what will not work.
他用种族做了实验，所以我们可以从种族IAT开始，其中70%的白人和甚至亚洲人都将白色与好联系在一起，将黑色与坏联系在一起。
You get to, if you put the work into building that kind of experiment, he'll load it up on the website and get data on it and tell all of us which ones worked and which ones didn't. and a paper was published with many authors to show which ones worked and which ones didn't. So interventions that he tried came in three different categories. Intervention number one, you tell the subject, try to be egalitarian. Do not be biased. Try to treat these two groups equally. The second is you don't say anything to them, but you just give them new associations. So you pair black with good things, white with not so good things, to see
干预措施一：你告诉受试者，尽量保持平等主义。
if that will just shift the IAT bias away from the default in our society and towards whatever you've just taught people. If that works, then that tells us that even implicit biases are open to intervention and to change. So that's number two. I call that sort of the associative measure method or kind of like a brute force method. We're just going to give you new associations to see if they will replace the old ones. And the third intervention is something that I think only humans can do.
我把这称为关联测量方法或某种蛮力方法。
You know, we can take any other animal other than us, take non-human animals and give them new associations. And they'll learn those, as we would. But there is something unique to humans, and that's language and the ability to be able to soar in our minds and think entirely new thoughts. And so the third kind of intervention is one where you are asked to imagine, imagine. Imagine a world in which you're suffering in some way, and a person from group A, black, helps you, while a person from group B, white, does not help you.
你知道，除了我们之外，我们可以带任何其他动物，带非人类动物，给它们新的联想。
So you imagine that. Does that matter? And the data show that what works is exactly the opposite order of the way I gave you the three categories. If you use that kind of linguistically based thinking, imagining, somebody helps you that produces the biggest change of the IAT. You actually begin to become more pro-black than you were before, or less empty black than you were before.
想象一下。
The second method, the associations, they work, but not as powerfully. And this was a surprise to us, because I had been thinking that that one would work the best. The IAT's measuring associations were messing directly with the association, so that should produce the biggest effect. It does not. This is why I love science, you know, that every day I can make a hypothesis and what are my students will show me, I'm wrong. And now we know something. We know something new and better.
这就是为什么我热爱科学，你知道，我每天都可以提出一个假设，而我的学生会向我展示，我是错的。
And the worst method, the one that actually has no effect at all, is to tell people to be good people, to be egalitarian and so on. So let me say that this may make it sound like, oh, so it's easy to change. It is easy in the sense that it will last for a short period of time, but it won't last very long. You step out of that experiment and you enter the real world, and the real world is again giving you data that make the same old, same old association between black and bad, white and good, and so your brain snaps back. Now, when young people encounter this result, when they see that, yes, they were able to make change, but the change doesn't last, they get very sad because they want a better world. And I'm not at all sad about that. I think it's telling us the exact truth about how the human mind. mind works. Can you imagine this? We are giving people a tiny little intervention, and it is producing a shift, but the shift does not last. Isn't that a wonderful thing? Because think about all the
而最糟糕的方法，也就是那种完全没有效果的方法，就是告诉人们要做好人、要平等之类的话。所以我想说，这可能会让人觉得，哦，改变起来很简单。从短期来看确实很容易，但不会持续太久。你走出那个实验，进入现实世界，而现实世界再次向你提供数据，让你在黑人与坏、白人与好之间建立起老一套的联想，于是你的大脑又弹回去了。现在，去年轻人遇到这个结果时，当他们看到，是的，他们能够做出改变，但改变却无法持久时，他们会感到非常难过，因为他们想要一个更好的世界。我对此一点也不难过。我认为这告诉了我们关于人类思维如何运作的绝对真理。你能想象吗？我们给人们一个微小的干预，它产生了一种转变，但这种转变并没有持续下去。这不是一件奇妙的事吗？因为想想所有这些
apologize for the word, the crap that we hear all the time, you know, imagine if that were to stick forever, you wouldn't want that kind of a brain. So our brains change, our minds change, associations move around, but they always will gravitate to whatever is your cultural default. And so to bring about actual change, society around us has to change. And then we will move, and then the default will be a new default. So I'm not bothered by this result. I would never predict that the effect should last very long because it would be a dangerous thing if the effects lasted long, because we don't get to choose everything we see in here. So it's a good that we get to snap back to something.
请原谅我用这个词，也就是我们一直听到的那些废话，你知道，想象一下如果那种想法永远留存下来，你肯定不会想要那种大脑。所以我们的大脑在改变，我们的思维在改变，各种联想在四处移动，但它们总是会回归到你的文化默认值。因此，要实现真正的改变，我们周围的社会必须改变。然后我们才会改变，接着默认值就会变成一个新的默认值。所以我并不为这个结果烦恼。我从不预测这种效应能持续很长时间，因为如果效应持续很久的话将会是一件危险的事，因为我们无法选择我们在其中看到的一切。所以，能够弹回到某种状态是一件好事。
So you've been studying implicit bias for decades now, and you have found some evidence that in recent years, some of our biases have decreased. What is happening? How has that happened? How are we measuring it? And what are the biases that are different than they might have been 10 or 20 years ago? It is among the most exciting work that's been happening in my lab. And the person to credit here is a brilliant postdoc, was a graduate student.
所以你研究隐性偏见已经几十年了，你发现了一些证据，表明近年来我们的一些偏见已经减少了。发生了什么？这是怎么发生的？我们是如何测量它的？与10年或20年前相比，现在的偏见有什么不同？这是我实验室里进行的最令人兴奋的工作之一。这里应该归功于一位才华横溢的博士后，他曾是一名研究生。
Tessa Charlesworth. As you know, we opened the website where implicit bias tests were made available in 1998. And here's the story about the beginning of it. There was very little on the internet. There was no psychology experiment happening on the internet. The internet was not very well developed. People then, even large corporations would have kind of one picture with their name and some URL and some phone numbers. That was what was on the internet. And, you know, here we are, we say, let's put these tests on the internet after four, four years of testing it internally in the lab. Once we felt we had a good handle on what it was doing and all the variations that we needed to do to establish basic issues, we put these tests on a
苔丝·查尔斯沃思（Tessa Charlesworth）。如你所知，我们在1998年开通了提供隐性偏见测试的网站。故事的开始是这样的。当时互联网上的内容非常少。互联网上没有任何心理学实验。当时互联网发展得并不好。那时候，即使是大公司也只有一张带有名字、某个网址和一些电话号码的图片。这就是互联网上的内容。你知道，当时我们说，在实验室内部测试了四年之后，让我们把这些测试放到互联网上吧。一旦我们觉得自己对它在做什么有了很好的把握，并且掌握了为了确立基本问题所需的所有各种变化，我们就把这些测试放到了一个
website and we thought, and I remember very explicitly saying to my two colleagues, Tony Greenwald, and Brian Nosek, who actually built the website, I said to them, wouldn't it be amazing? like we don't have to bring one subject in at a time. And maybe in a year we'll have 500 people who will have taken this test and we'll have so much data and they won't even be, you know, Yale and University of Washington students. So people will actually have to take these data seriously because they will come from real people, not from college students. I mean, we were so naive because in the very first month after the site opened, we had 45,000 completed tests. And we were not only taken aback, we had to figure out a coping strategy because people were now writing to us. Dozens of messages in a given day.
网站上，而且我记得我非常明确地对我的两个同事托尼·格林沃尔德（Tony Greenwald）和布莱恩·诺塞克（Brian Nosek）说过，——实际上是布莱恩·诺塞克搭建了这个网站——我对他们说，这难道不神奇吗？就像我们不必一次只带一个受试者进来一样。也许一年内就会有500人参加这个测试，我们将拥有如此多的数据，而且他们甚至不会是（你知道的）耶鲁大学和华盛顿大学的学生。所以人们真的会不得不认真对待这些数据，因为它们来自真实的人，而不是大学生。我的意思是，我们太天真了，因为在网站开通的第一个月，我们就完成了45,000份测试。我们不仅大吃一惊，还不得不找出应对策略，因为人们现在开始给我们写信了。一天之内就有几十条消息。
Your test is stupid. You know, I am not, I do not have a race bias. I am a rap musician. How dare you tell me I'm. So this is what we had to deal with. Anyway, to make a long story short, you know, we think something like maybe we don't count anymore, but there at least 40 million tests have been now taking. and we have an awful lot of data. From about 2007, because we were fiddling with things and we were just getting used to how to build it,
你的测试太蠢了。你知道的，我不是，我没有种族偏见。我是一名说唱音乐家。你怎么敢说我是。所以这就是我们不得不处理的事情。总之，长话短说，你知道，我们觉得可能我们不再被计算在内了，但现在至少已经进行了大约4000万次测试，我们拥有大量的数据。从2007年左右开始，因为我们在调整各种事情，并且刚刚习惯了如何构建它，
we don't believe that the data we got before 2007 were as stable, as reliable, as good as the data from 2007 onwards. So from there onwards, there are lots of data, and the group has put these data on a public website. So anybody can go there. Anybody can take those data and analyze them. and in fact, many people have. So Tessa Charlesworth decided to look at what has happened over time. These are not your typical psychological analyses, right? We do do some longitudinal work.
我们认为2007年之前得到的数据不如2007年及之后的数据那么稳定、可靠和优质。所以从那时起，有大量的数据，团队已经将这些数据放到了一个公开的网站上。所以任何人都可以去那里。任何人都可以获取这些数据并进行分析，事实上，许多人也确实这样做了。因此，苔丝·查尔斯沃思决定研究随着时间的推移发生了什么。这些并不是你典型的心理学分析，对吧？我们确实做一些纵向研究。
Developmental psychologists do study what happens to a child as the child develops and so on. But this data set, I think, is so I generous. There is no such database where we've been. been collecting data continuously 24-7 since 2007 to today. So it's just unusual, you know, a gallop poll, however wonderful it might be, is going to go in and in a single moment get data from 2,500 people or whatever and then conclude that Americans do this or that. We're collecting data every second, every minute, you know, of the day and night because we also opened a bunch of international sites. And so truly data are being collected around.
发展心理学家确实会研究儿童在成长过程中发生的事情等等。但我认为这个数据集是如此慷慨。没有哪个数据库能像我们这样，从2007年到今天，全天候24小时持续收集数据。所以这很不寻常，你知道，盖洛普民意调查无论多么棒，也会在某个单一时刻获取2500人左右的数据，然后得出结论说美国人做了这个或那个。我们一年到头每一秒、每一分钟都在收集数据，因为我们也开通了许多国际网站。所以数据确实在夜以继日地被收集。
around the clock. And we have, for many tests, take race, which is a very popular test, we now have data from dozens and dozens of people in every little location, every county of the United States. So what we can say is, okay, we've got that big, big fat pool of data. Can we look to see if anything has changed in 2007 to today? And again, I should tell you, I was hesitant about even taking this on because I was so persuaded that implicit bias cannot change in the long term that I thought, okay, do this as an exercise for your statistics class, but it's not really something that, you know, we'll be able to say anything about. We will be able to say, I think.
日夜不停。对于许多测试，比如种族测试（这是一个非常受欢迎的测试），我们现在拥有美国每一个小地点、每一个县的成千上万人的数据。所以我们可以说，好吧，我们有了那个庞大而丰富的数据池。我们能不能看看2007年到今天有什么变化？再次说明，我应该告诉你，我甚至对承担这项工作感到犹豫，因为我太确信隐性偏见在长期内是无法改变的，以至于我想，好吧，把这个当作你统计学课的一个练习吧，但它并不是那种（你知道的）我们能够说出点什么的事情。我想我们能够说的是，
Nothing has changed. It's implicit bias in my mind, having looked at the data, having studied it for about 20 years by then, more than that, 30 years maybe. I was quite persuaded that we would see flat lines over time 2007 to when we first did the analysis 2016. No change. And maybe we should write about that. Maybe we should say, look, implicit bias is not changing, et cetera. So Tessa not only did the analysis, she did it not just for one or two groups, but for six of them.
什么都没有改变。在我的脑海中，在看过这些数据、研究了大约20年甚至更长时间（也许30年）之后，我非常确信，从2007年到我们2016年首次进行分析这段时间里，我们会看到平坦的曲线。没有变化。也许我们应该写写这个。也许我们应该说，看吧，隐性偏见并没有改变，等等。所以苔丝不仅做了分析，她不仅为一个或两个群体做了分析，而是为其中的六个群体做了分析。
She looked at anti-gay bias. She looked at race bias. She looked at skin tone bias, which is a little different than race. bias, of course, age bias, disability, and body weight bias. So there are six different kinds of categories. And what she discovered that surprised us is that on three of those tests, you do see substantial change. I'll begin with the one that showed such big change that we're still gobsmacked from having seen those data. And that's anti-gay bias. So anti-gay bias has dropped off by 64% between 2007 and 2020. How can this be? How can a bias that was so high in 2007,
她研究了反同性恋偏见。她研究了种族偏见。她研究了肤色偏见，这当然与种族偏见略有不同，还有年龄偏见、残疾偏见和体重偏见。所以有六种不同的类别。她发现的事情让我们感到惊讶，那就是在这其中的三项测试中，你确实看到了实质性的变化。我先从那项展现出如此巨大变化、以至于我们看到这些数据时至今仍惊愕不已的测试开始。那就是反同性恋偏见。所以，反同性恋偏见在2007年至2020年间下降了64%。这怎么可能？一种在2007年如此高的偏见，
it was one of the large biases, gay, bad, straight good. How come that bias has been just withering away at this speed? And remarkably, if you look at any demographic group in the country, you can look at elderly people, young people, you can look at people who live in the coasts in the middle of the country, the north, the south, the rich, the poor, the educated, the less educated. You can look at any of these. And we see change in every single group. So everybody's changing on this. Yes, there are two groups that are changing faster than everybody. Your listeners should try to predict what those groups might be. And as they do that, I'll give the answer. Younger people are changing faster.
它是最大的偏见之一，即同性恋=坏，异性恋=好。为什么这种偏见会以这样的速度逐渐消退？值得注意的是，如果你看看这个国家的任何一个群体，你可以看看老年人、年轻人，你可以看看住在海岸边的人、住在国家中部的人、北方人、南方人、富人、穷人、受过教育的人、受教育较少的人。你可以看看其中的任何一个。我们在每一个单一的群体中都看到了变化。所以每个人都在这方面发生改变。是的，有两个群体的改变速度比其他人更快。你们的听众可以尝试预测一下这些群体可能是哪些。在他们这样做的同时，我会给出答案。年轻人改变得更快，
and people who are self-professed liberals are also changing faster. In fact, those two groups have pulled away from their original bias in 2007 so fast that they are today at neutrality. Wow. For them, gay and straight are equally good and bad. The rest of us will catch up. So one of the nice things about this analysis, these are called time series analysis. And we use a particular model called Arema for those who are. who might want to go look up what it is.
自称是自由派的人也改变得更快。事实上，这两个群体在2007年迅速脱离了他们最初的偏见，以至于他们今天达到了中立状态。哇。对他们来说，同性恋和异性恋同样好也同样坏。我们其他人会赶上来的。所以这项分析的好处之一是，这些被称为时间序列分析。对于那些可能想去查阅它是什么的人，我们使用了一种称为求和自回归移动平均模型（Arima）的特定模型。
There are lots of limitations to this method. We have to make very sure that we're not just showing this effect because all of a sudden, in recent years, there are many more young people taking the test than they were before. That would not be a correct way to interpret the data to say there is changed. It's not really changed. It's just that the sample has more young people today and didn't have as many young people. So you have to rule out lots and lots of things.
这种方法有很多局限性。我们必须非常确定，我们展示这种效应并不是因为近年来突然有更多的年轻人参加测试，而以前没有。将数据解释为“有变化”并不是一种正确的方式。这其实并不是真正的变化，只是今天的样本中有更多的年轻人，而以前没有那么多年轻人。所以你必须排除许许多多的事情。
So if they're interested, they should go look at this paper. that was published in psychological science. And what they will see if you get into the data is that this change, we think, is real. This is a real shift in what people are thinking. And when I tell people that these days, they say, oh, yes, of course. I could have predicted that that would happen.
因此，如果他们感兴趣，他们应该去看看这篇发表在《心理科学》（Psychological Science）上的论文。如果你深入了解这些数据，你会看到的是，我们认为这种变化是真实的。这是人们思想上的一次真实转变。当我这些天告诉人们这一点时，他们会说，哦，是的，当然。我本可以预测到会发生这种事。
Well, you know, as we know, hindsight is 2020, and they can. But in retrospect, I too now see why this might have happened. So I would love for your listeners while we talk to be thinking about this. Why did sexuality bias change? Because no other bias has changed as fast. Race bias has changed, but by 25%. Okay. So good news is it has moved. But we can ask, why not at the level of 64%. We know that's possible. So why is race slow? Why is skin tone bias going down? Again, by 25%. Why is it not as fast as sexuality? We know that,
好吧，正如我们所知，事后诸葛亮总是百分之百准确，他们确实能预测。但现在回想起来，我也明白了为什么这可能会发生。所以我很乐意让你们的听众在我们的谈话中思考这个问题。为什么性取向偏见会改变？因为没有任何其他偏见改变得这么快。种族偏见确实改变了，但幅度是25%。好吧。好消息是它已经发生了变化。但我们可以问，为什么没有达到64%的水平？我们知道这是可能的。那么为什么种族偏见很慢呢？为什么肤色偏见在下降？同样，下降了25%。为什么它不像性取向那样快？我们知道，
gender bias, home and career bias, has come down by about that much, but why so slow? The association that men are for STEM and science and math and women okay for arts and so on, that bias has, but not as much as the anti-gay bias has. There are three biases that have not shifted much at all, in fact. And that's anti-elderly bias, which continues on and is absolutely stable, a little bit lower, but not anything to write home about. Disability bias, just flat since 2007, no change. And bodyweight bias, a bias against people who are overweight, that remains flat, and that looks like the hardest one in some ways in the data that will change. we think these biases are going to be around.
性别偏见、家庭与职业偏见已经下降了大约那么多，但为什么这么慢？男人适合STEM、科学和数学，而女人适合艺术等等的这种关联偏见已经有所下降，但远没有反同性恋偏见下降得那么多。事实上，有三种偏见几乎没有什么转变。这就是反老年人偏见，它持续存在且绝对稳定，稍微低了一点，但没有什么值得大惊小怪的。残疾偏见，自2007年以来一直持平，没有变化。体重偏见，一种针对超重人群的偏见，仍然保持平稳，在数据中这似乎是某种程度上最难改变的一种。我们认为这些偏见将会一直存在。
If they move at this rate, we're not going to see change for 200 years. That's our prediction. So then what is it that special about anti-gay bias? And I'd like to put a few ideas out and then see if your listeners would agree. I think that sexuality bias changed because it became personal in some way. That is to say, parents and grandparents, friends, neighbors, cousins, we all discover. the people who were close to us, said to us, I'm gay. That became possible.
如果它们以这种速度移动，我们在200年内都不会看到变化。这是我们的预测。那么，反同性恋偏见的特别之处究竟在哪里呢？我想提出几个想法，然后看看你们的听众是否同意。我认为性取向偏见之所以改变，是因为它在某种程度上变得个人化了。也就是说，父母和祖父母、朋友、邻居、表亲，我们都发现，那些与我们亲近的人对我们说，我是同性恋。这成为了可能。
And as they began to come out, we would have confronted a state of dissonance, of cognitive dissonance, this old idea in psychology. I believe being gay is bad. Here's my child saying, she's gay. I have to do something in my head to resolve this conflict. And Leon Fester, the genius in the 1950s who wrote about this theory of cognitive dissidents said, we can't maintain these. We have to change one or the other.
当他们开始出柜时，我们将会面临一种不和谐状态，即认知失调的状态——这是心理学中的一个老概念。我认为同性恋是坏的。这里我的孩子说，她是同性恋。我必须在我的脑海中做点什么来解决这个冲突。莱昂·费斯廷格（Leon Festinger）是20世纪50年代撰写关于这种认知失调理论的天才，他说，我们无法维持这些。我们必须改变其中之一。
Either you have to cut off relations with your child and say, I disown you. Or you can begin to say, I think being gay is not the horrible thing that the Bible told me or whatever, however you came to those beliefs. And what we have found is that maybe it would have gone the other way. I had this happened two centuries ago, but given the time in which we live and the meaning of what religion is to many of us, where we believe that it might be a guide to certain ways of living a good life, but that we may not want to take the Bible. So literally or whatever. It just so happened that people went with love. The love of the child, the love of your neighbor or your friend trumped this other belief.
要么你必须切断与孩子的关系，说，我与你断绝关系。或者你可以开始说，我认为同性恋并不是圣经或其他什么东西告诉我的那种可怕的事情，无论你是如何形成这些信仰的。我们发现的是，也许事情会走向另一个方向。如果两个世纪前发生这种事，但鉴于我们生活的时代以及宗教对我们许多人的意义（我们相信它可能是通往美好生活的某种生活方式的指南，但我们可能不想把圣经看得那么字面化或其他什么），事情恰好是人们选择了爱。对孩子的爱、对邻居或朋友的爱压倒了这种其他的信仰。
And so we've seen change. This does not happen for anti-elderly bias, for race. where we are so segregated. And think about race. You know, the two big domains in which we live and do our stuff are home, the neighborhood, the family, and work. And in both those domains, we're deeply segregated by race. We just don't see people across race lines because it gets intersected with socioeconomic
所以我们看到了改变。这并没有发生在使用反老年人偏见和种族偏见上，在这些领域我们是如此地被隔离。想想种族。你知道，我们生活和做事的两个主要领域是家庭、邻里、家庭和工作。在这两个领域中，我们按种族进行了深刻的隔离。我们只是看不到跨越种族界限的人，因为它与社会经济
class and so on. So the chance that you would meet that person and have the same kind of. of experience that, you know, straight parents and straight grandparents had to deal with when the time came, that just is not an opportunity that race offers us. So as a society, we have to ask ourselves, what will we do if we care about race bias? The second thing that happened for sexuality is that Hollywood got involved. Institutions are deeply important. To Hollywood, this particular dimension matters because there is a larger number of gay people in the entertainment industry than many other industries. I think they cared about it. So they did something remarkable. They made movies
阶层等因素相交织。因此，你遇到那个人并拥有与直人父母和直人祖父母在时机到来时必须处理的同种经历的机会，那根本不是种族提供给我们的机会。因此，作为一个社会，我们必须问自己，如果我们关心种族偏见，我们会做什么？对于性取向发生的第二件事是好莱坞介入了。体制是极其重要的。对好莱坞而言，这个特定的维度很重要，因为娱乐产业中的同性恋人数比许多其他产业要多。我认为他们在乎这一点。所以他们做了一件非凡的事。他们制作了电影
and they made TV shows, not just ordinary ones, but ones in which the gay character would be cooler and smarter and nicer than the straight people on the show. And I don't know, people watched those and came to see that this was being normalized. And we're very sensitive to that. What do other people in our culture think? If I hear that, you know, 90% of my neighbors are saving energy by doing certain things, I become very competitive and I want to be better than them and I will do it. Much more so than if you ask me to be a good person and care about the environment, that doesn't do very much.
他们制作了电视节目，不仅仅是普通的节目，而是其中的同性恋角色比节目中的直人更酷、更聪明、更好的节目。我不知道，人们观看了这些节目，并开始看到这正在变得正常化。我们对此非常敏感。我们文化中的其他人是怎么想的？如果我听到（你知道的）90%的邻居通过做某些事情在节约能源，我就会变得非常好胜，我想比他们做得更好，我也会去做。这远比你要求我做一个好人并关心环境要有效得多，后者并不能起到多大作用。
But hearing that other people do. We're very competitive, yes. They're very competitive, especially socially, of course. So I think that that helped a great deal. And then, of course, the hand of government came in. The Massachusetts Supreme Court first said gay marriages legalized. I remember I had moved to Cambridge only a couple years before this happened. And Boston announced that it would open its courtrooms on whatever it was Monday morning at 9 a.m.
但是听到其他人也在做。我们确实非常好胜，对吧。他们非常好胜，当然，尤其是在社交方面。所以我觉得这在很大程度上起到了帮助作用。然后，当然，政府之手介入了。马萨诸塞州最高法院首先宣布同性婚姻合法化。我记得在这件事发生前几年我刚搬到剑桥。波士顿宣布它将在某个星期一早晨9点开启法庭大门
and performed the first gay marriages. And Cambridge, the suburb, not wanting to be second, decided that it would always open its courtrooms at one minute past midnight to be the first city to do it. So having lived in a town that was the first and having stood there watching the first gay, married couples walking out, it was clear that this was a moment, something historic had just happened. So now think about this. How many times in our history has change come about at three days.
并举行首场同性婚礼。而剑桥作为郊区，不甘落后，决定总是在午夜过一分钟开启法庭大门，成为第一个这样做的城市。所以，既然在一个成为第一的城镇生活过，并且站在那里看着第一对同性已婚夫妇走出来，很显然，这是一个时刻，刚刚发生了某种具有历史意义的事情。所以现在想想这个。在我们的历史上有多少次，改变是在三个不同层面上发生的——
different levels, the individual, the organizational or institutional, and at the level of governmental policies and the law within a short period of time. Yes, the civil rights movement in the 60s did something at that third level, but I don't think that we changed much at the institutional or individual levels. So it could not have the same impact as I think this did. So this is a very important lesson for us, that if we want to make change, maybe one of the messages from our researchers that try and do it at all three levels. And for that reason, I think we should be pleased that people in our society today use the word systemic so much more than we have. Systemic does not mean systematic. Systemic means that the system needs to get engaged. And I would like to argue
不同的层面，即个人层面、组织或体制层面，以及在短时间内政府政策和法律的层面。是的，60年代的民权运动在第三个层面做了一些事情，但我认为我们在体制或个人层面并没有太大改变。所以它不可能产生我认为这所能产生的相同影响。因此，这对我们来说是一个非常重要的课，如果我们想要做出改变，也许我们研究人员的信息之一就是尝试在所有三个层面上进行改变。出于这个原因，我认为我们应该感到高兴的是，今天我们社会中的人们使用“系统性”（systemic）这个词的频率比以前高得多。系统性并不意味着系统化。系统性意味着系统需要参与进来。我想争辩的是
that the system consists of individual people, the system consists of institutions, the system consists of large governmental organizations that can move certain kinds of levers. I cannot say that one is more important than the other, but I would like to argue that if we go for system change, we will see change a lot faster. Well, Dr. Banaji, this has been amazingly interesting.
系统由个体人员组成，系统由机构组成，系统由能够推动某种杠杆的大型政府组织组成。我不能说哪一个比另一个更重要，但我倾向于认为，如果我们追求系统性变革，我们会看到改变发生得快得多。好吧，巴纳吉博士，这真是太有趣了。
I really appreciate you're taking the time and explaining all of this to our listeners. I'm sure that they're going to enjoy hearing all of this and and taking the IAT. We'll get you some more data, I promise. Yes, and I'll get lots of little nasty notes at the end of that. Oh, I hope not. No, actually, I should, I should mention that the site is incredibly successful. I mean, the very moving letters that we have received, even from people who initially did not approve of the result that they got. And that is what gives me such faith in human beings, that the same people who wrote to us to say pretty nasty things will write back
非常感谢您抽出时间向我们的听众解释这一切。我确信他们会喜欢听到这一切并参加IAT测试。我保证我们会为您提供更多数据。是的，在这之后我会收到很多讨厌的小纸条。哦，我希望不会。不，事实上，我应该，我应该提到这个网站取得了令人难以置信的成功。我的意思是，我们收到了非常感人的信件，甚至来自那些最初并不赞成他们所得到结果的人。这就是为什么我对人类抱有如此大的信心，因为那些曾给我们写信说相当难听的话的同一个人会回信
later and say, I just had this experience and I wanted you to know that I understood what your stupid test was trying to tell me. Success. Thanks very much for having. It's a pleasure. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.combeckycology.org or on Apple Stitcher or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyin.
后来又说，我刚刚有了这段经历，我想让你知道，我理解你的愚蠢测试试图告诉我什么。成功了。非常感谢您的光临。这是我的荣幸。您可以在我们的网站 www.combeckycology.org 上，或者在 Apple、Stitcher 以及您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学对话》（Speaking of Psychology）之前的单集。如果您对未来的播客有评论或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。《心理学对话》由李·威纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·孔丁（Chris Kondyin）。
Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢您的收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学协会。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。